[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host and contributor to football
night in America we're just talking
about the Justin Jefferson fumble
through the end zone where do you stand
on this and is there any chance that a
standalone game moment like this could
change the rule at any point I hate the
rule it's a reflection of an outdated
approach toward the sanctity of the end
zone you know there was a time where an
incomplete pass if it landed in the end
zone resulted in a Touchback for the
defense
that has changed now it's just unfair
the idea that the defense did nothing to
recover the football and if the fumble
had gone out of Bounds at the one
millimeter line it's the offenses ball
at the spot of the fumble but if it
trickles across the front of the goal
line it suddenly is awarded to the
defense First and Ten at the 20. at a
minimum put the ball at the spot of the
fumble why do you get it at the 20. none
of it makes any sense to me and it will
never change unless and until it happens
in a Super Bowl at a key moment because
Dan here's what will happen after last
night we'll huff and puff about it today
and then here comes a bunch of bright
shiny objects on Sunday and we forget
about it and then whatever happens in
those games we'll complain about it and
then Monday bright shiny object and then
Thursday bright shiny object it takes
the last game of the year with a big
audience of casual fans who when they
learn of this rule will say
what the hell is that well that makes no
sense that's the kind of outcry it's
going to take because Dan one thing I've
learned
over the years teams that get burned by
a rule like this they don't complain all
that much about it because they think
the next time it's going to help us and
that's the reality with this rule it's a
50 50 thing everybody who gets burned by
it well somebody else gets helped by it
and you think over time it's all going
to even out so we're fine with it until
somebody loses a Super Bowl over it okay
what would be your solution
put the ball at the spot of the fumble
offense gets it it should be no
different than if it goes out of Bounds
at the one inch line it goes to the
offense at the spot of the fumble what
has the defense done to justify
possession again it reflects an outdated
view of some sort of sanctity of the end
zone and its enemy territory and if you
lose possession of the ball in our
territory we get the ball I don't like
it I don't think it reflects the modern
approach to offense and scoring and it
just seems unfair to award the ball to
the other team when they have done
nothing to recover possession of the
ball all right you're talking about
modern offenses the quarterback sneak
with the Eagles that uh I think that was
up for debate in the off season the big
push that they're able to do that I
don't know if anybody else has mastered
this quite like the Eagles have but then
not many teams have an offensive line
like the Eagles have why are they
allowing this to continue
this one's bizarre to me Dan and I got
to take you back 17 years prior to 2006
it was against the rules to push a
runner from behind to assist him or pull
the runner around 2006 they realized you
know what we never throw the flag for
assisting the runner and we used to see
it downfield guys fighting for a first
down here comes the offensive line ah
boom and pushes him past the yellow line
they were never calling a foul so they
took it out of the rule book and it took
a generation almost for a team to look
at it and say you know what we can like
incorporate that into our offense if
you're allowed to push the runner let's
push him from the snap and the Eagles
have perfected it there was debate in
the off season about getting rid of it
I'm surprised they didn't muster enough
votes to do it because this isn't one of
those rules that benefits everyone at
some point this is one that's benefiting
one team that is willing to constantly
put its quarterback In Harm's Way with
this play and eventually maybe he gets
injured during that play but it's just
ugly it's not something that you know
there's no drama to it it's automatic I
think the NFL is looking for moments of
Greater drama and uncertainty when they
line up like that you know they're going
to convert it no one has an answer for
it so I think it was close last year and
if it continues this year it's it should
be the last year that it's in the game
Andrew Luck retired four years ago
saying he needed to quote remove himself
from football
well he's back he's on the field and
he's a coach at Palo Alto High School
right across from where he played his
college ball I saw that you had an
article on Pro Football Talk where could
the Jets reach out to Andrew Luck and at
least gauge interest now is that that
would be tampering can so would they
have to go through the Colts to then ask
about Andrew Luck to get permission is
that how it works yeah they'd have to
call the Colts and get permission to
talk to Andrew Luck and if they were
going to desire to sign Andrew Luck and
if he was willing to come back and play
they'd have to do a trade with the Colts
before they require him and we know that
because there was a story earlier this
year that in 2022 when the commanders
were turning every stone looking for a
quarterback and ultimately found Carson
Wentz
they reached out to Andrew Locke and Jim
irce went to Twitter and said anybody
who contacts Andrew Luck without our
permission is committing a violation of
the tampering rules so we're already on
notice now the reality is I was told by
someone last night Dan Marino is more
likely to come back at this point so
it's all academic it's not going to
happen and I think the Jets are all in
with Zach Wilson they're not looking for
someone to come in and supplant Wilson
at least not yet they're looking for a
backup to come in and be an understudy
to Zach Wilson they're in for now with
the plan that Wilson is the guy and
let's see what happens
we're talking to Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host with Chris
Simpson who's the backup for the Jets
Tim Boyle okay right now there's only
one quarterback on the act of roster
they'll bring boil up from the practice
squad for Sunday's game and I assume
maybe next week they'll do something
they tried to sign Brett Rippon off the
Rams practice squad he decided to sign
with the Rams active roster he was with
Nathaniel Hackett in Denver last year
Hackett obviously now the Jets offensive
coordinator so that's the kind of guy
they're looking for they want to to
Rally around Wilson and why shouldn't
that I mean I saw the guy get criticized
for how he played on Monday night they
beat the bills he came into the worst
possible situation you could imagine
four snaps into the season Aaron Rodgers
is done Hey kid grab your helmet and get
your ass out there anyone out there any
won the game can you win a Super Bowl
with Zach Wilson
can you
yes if your defense is
is as good as some of the members of the
Jets defense seem to think it is if it's
2 000 Ravens 2002 bucks 85 Bears it's
almost sacrilegious to even say that but
DJ Reed said it not that long ago and
you've got Rhys Hall and Alvin cook if
you construct a game plan week in and
week out that focuses on what Zach
Wilson can do and and don't expect him
to do so much don't expect him to be the
hero you could win enough games you know
maybe you thread a needle or two and you
get lucky and you could get there and
win it I I it's in in this year's AFC
it I think it takes a great quarterback
to win in the playoffs and it's going to
take great quarterback play a big throw
in a big spot to win those games and do
you think Zach Wilson can do that
well let's fast forward to
the postseason I mean if they get there
he presumably will build more confidence
he will get better with good experience
they win games it becomes kind of an
avalanche so maybe he's a guy who by the
time they get to the playoffs he can
perform like the guy everyone thought he
was going to be you know every time
there's a quarterback bus the team gets
accused of reaching nobody was saying
Zach Wilson shouldn't have been the
second overall pick in the draft it was
a given it was Trevor Lawrence Zach
Wilson right when the 49ers traded up we
knew the first two guys off the board
Lawrence Wilson and then the 49ers had
their pick of the rest so this wasn't
some crazy outside the box thing Wilson
was regarded as the number two talent in
the 2021 draft and now he gets a reset
he gets a chance to start over and build
some confidence by the time we get to
January if they make it maybe he will be
good enough to make that big throw he's
got the physical skills to do it okay if
you're the Rams or the Vikings
and the Jets reached out
Matthew Stafford that contract you
probably couldn't bring him in could you
bring in Kirk Cousins uh these are two
teams that probably aren't going to be
playoff bound if they are they're going
to be on the periphery but if you're the
Jets it's about winning a Super Bowl
you could upgrade with Stafford and or
Kirk D cousins could you see that
happening well remember when the Vikings
lost Teddy Bridgewater in late August of
2016 and they thought they had a team
that could contend they gave a first
round pick and a fourth round pick to
the Eagles for Sam Bradford it didn't
work out but they felt compelled to do
it so if the Jets were going to go that
route the Rams are out of the question
at this point even though the Jets had
Stafford as their plan B to Aaron
Rodgers once Stafford had like a 57
million dollar payment become guaranteed
the Rams can't trade him now because
next year they would take a 55.5 million
dollar dead cap charge if they trade him
now no acceleration against the cap now
but next year how do you put a team on
the field when you got 55.5 million
under Matthew Stafford's name with
cousins
plan out a few weeks Vikings lose to the
Chargers next week let's say let's say
they go to Carolina and lay an egg and
then the Chiefs come to town I mean you
get to 014015 one in five two and six
trade deadline the Tuesday after week
eight
I mean the problem is
are you really going to be in position
to throw in the towel on the season if
you're the Vikings even if you're
one in seven through eight games it's
it's too early and Nick Mullins is your
backup quarterback unless they they
start talking up Jaren Hall the rookie
from BYU and they're like hey he's ready
to go and we want to see what he can do
and we want to evaluate him but I I
think for now the Jets want to make it
work with Zach Wilson also the Jets
first two draft picks for 2024 are tied
up in this Rogers deal it's a
conditional second round first round
pick they can't trade either of those
picks even though it's only going to be
the second round pick at the end of the
day those two picks are frozen so they'd
have to come up with some other way to
get a Kirk Cousins or a Matthew Stafford
the most winnish game this weekend must
winish
you know I I want to say
that there is no must win game week two
but that's a cop-out we got to pick one
of them I think the bills are under the
most pressure because I've been saying
for the past few weeks the bills to me
feel like you know that game Jenga when
you're about 20 moves into it and every
every
plank that you move it just starts doing
this I feel like the bills are just
doing this and it's just a matter of
time before it all falls down this whole
Josh Allen thing with all these
turnovers like do they not have anyone
Dan that that can go to him on the
sideline in the middle of a game and say
calm down here's what we need to do
there is here's the Playbook there is no
play in here that results in 21 points
with one throw of the ball we've got to
run the offense the way it's designed
you can't go out there and be a hero I
know you're frustrated that we're not
beating the Jets by 30 points even with
Aaron Rodgers out I know but we got to
run the offense Ken Dorsey is not the
guy to do it we saw how excitable he is
remember after the loss to the Dolphins
last year and he's throwing stuff around
in the booth and Sean McDermott's
running the defense this year he's
calling the plays defensively so he
can't say hey time out somebody else
called the plays I gotta go talk to the
quarterback and get his mind right the
problem is he tries to do too much and
we see athletes do this from time to
time where they have so much faith in
their abilities they try to do more than
they can and it gets them into trouble
and they get desperate and they can't
get out of it and if they lose to the
Raiders and Chris Sims picked the
Raiders to beat the bills gutsy move
week two if the Raiders beat the bills
this weekend they got a real problem in
Buffalo
Before I Let You Go the uh Dion Sanders
bandwagon two games into his Colorado
career and you already have people like
Michael Irvin saying he could be
successful as the next Dallas Cowboys
head coach you I think are on the Deion
Sanders bandwagon aren't you of could he
be
the next head coach of the Dallas
Cowboys
I would hire him to be the head coach of
an NFL team if I was the owner and I was
looking for a coach look at the end of
the day and people say oh that style
won't work on NFL players baloney when I
hear Deion Sanders speaking to his team
I'm 58 years old I want to get up and
run into the wall now I won't run
through the wall I'll bounce off of it
but if it motivates me how's it it's
going to motivate football I mean we all
have a desire Dan
to to have someone reach into us and
press that button that makes us go out
and be great and that's what Dion has
and when you listen to him and I don't
know if you saw the clip from a few
weeks ago that the Cardinals put out
there of their new coach Jonathan Gannon
how did you get here did your driver
take the bus what the hell is that like
Dion would work in the NFL and I I think
that they should be clamoring now when
you consider he can get it done and look
at all the attention and Buzz and you're
going to get Prime Time games and you're
going to be the focal point is so much
attention that's what these teams want
to do yeah they'd like to win but you
also want to sell a lot of merch you
want people to be excited you want your
team to be one of the hot teams and
whoever would go out and hire Deion
Sanders would be the hot team going into
that season I I I I think any smart
owner needs to be thinking about making
a move for Deion Sanders right now but
if you're Dion do you want to work under
Jerry Jones when you know that Jerry
wants to be the coach owner quarterback
and general manager well well that's
part of the problem and look Dion would
have options I don't know I think the
Cardinals are tanking now are they too
inept to properly tank we'll see I think
they'd like to get Caleb Williams and if
I'm Caleb Williams and Jonathan Gannon
is the coach of the Cardinals I say no
thank you if I'm Caleb Williams and they
brought in Deion Sanders to be the coach
of the Cardinals
I'm thinking maybe the Cardinals are
figuring out what it takes to be
successful in the NFL and I'll go play
for them
but does Dion maybe want to go where his
son is going to be the quarterback does
he if I ask Dion that I have to wait
till USC Colorado
who is uh going to be a better Pro Caleb
Williams or your son
that that's part that's part of all the
things to be determined this is the
season unfolds but but look it's it's
the biggest story in football I was
stunned last week Dan when I think it
was bet MGM reported that there was more
bets placed on the Colorado game than
any of the remaining NFL games for week
one and that rarely happens and it's
usually like Michigan Ohio State it was
Colorado Nebraska for crying out loud so
this guy is a magnet for attention he's
got that natural Charisma he knows how
to motivate players and I think he knows
how to win we're seeing it one week at a
time and every week there's going to be
some idiot that says something that
gives him low-hanging fruit he can use
to motivate his players
no uh motivation from from this segment
by you because no no I'm all in hey I
like great stories people ask me what do
you root for I root for great stories
and it would be a great story to have
Deion Sanders and as an NFL head coach
did you send flowers to Aaron Rodgers
I hey hey
I don't know if you've heard Hard Knocks
worked on me I've turned around on Aaron
Rodgers I like Aaron Rodgers now I like
this guy who's aware that his football
career is pulling into the station and
he's savoring every moment he's a
sympathetic figure to me now I feel
awful for him I was all in with the Jets
and Aaron Rodgers I I had changed my
tune so maybe I should maybe I should
send him some flowers this will cheer
him up right here oh I sure will yes it
will I'm sure he cares I'm sure I'm sure
it makes him feel better it probably
makes him feel worse to think that he's
actually changed my mind but I I hope he
comes back next year and I hope he plays
great next year and it really is it
really is sad that it happened for the
game for him for the Jets for everybody
we've been deprived whoop There goes my
microphone of what would have been a
really great season and uh hopefully
he'll be back next year thank you Mike
have a great weekend see you Dan hi Mike
Florio pro football talk he's there with
uh Chris Sims Monday through Friday
precedes our show